good morning believe nation its Evan my
one word is believe I believe in you and
I want to see that awesome thing that
you have inside you explode out into the
universe to have a major impact so to
help you on your journey today's message
is be rational over to you Warren
Buffett big thing is rationality and
there was you know I always look at IQ
and talent as sort of representing the
horsepower of the motor but then in
terms of the output the efficiency which
which the motor works that depends on
rationality because a lot of people
start out with four hundred horsepower
motors and get a hundred horsepower
about but and it's way better to have a
200 horsepower motor and get it all in
doubt put in and so why do why do smart
people do things that interfere with
really getting the yeah the output
they're entitled to and it's it gets
into the habits into character into
temperament and it really gets into
behaving in a rational manner it's not
letting not getting in your own way as I
say everybody here has the ability
absolutely to do anything I do and much
beyond and and some of you will and some
of you won't but it it will the ones
that won't
well because me because you get in your
own way it won't because the world
doesn't allow you to it will be because
you don't allow yourself to them the
thing that aggravates me the most in the
world is untapped potential it's the
opposite of belief it's seeing people
with an insane amount of genius inside
them just an insane amount of potential
and them not taking any action on it not
doing anything about it it just drives
me up the wall they're coasting they're
playing it safe they're not tapping into
what they've got and they're playing
small it's part of why I started this
channel because I wanted you guys to
believe in yourselves more to be
surrounded by a great environment to
have content to enrich your lives
hopefully in a daily basis and push you
to get that genius out of you to go out
and do amazing things so how do you tap
into that genius and then use it on a
daily basis for me it starts with
self-awareness so it's with
understanding
what you stand for right that's why I
wrote this book what is your most
important core value and then how do you
build a daily routine schedule in life
around it and so when you have that
self-awareness when you know what you
stand for it allows you to create a path
forward that is clear that allows you to
go really fast plus it'll go really far
where most people they don't have any
clue and so what you're doing is
constantly living up to what other
people expect of you right your boss
wants you to do this your parents wants
you to do this your customer wants you
to do this and you're so busy trying to
live up to other people's expectations
that you don't even know what you want
for yourself if you don't know what your
single most important core value is what
your one word is you're just gonna be
living up to other people's values and
then you're never going to be able to
create your own path where you have a
unique path you have genius inside of
you and you got to figure out how to
make that come out and so it means
believe and that oozes out of everything
that I make it comes out of this video
comes out of every videos that I put up
and it's not just me saying believe at
the beginning or the end of a video it's
not just wearing a shirt that says
believe on it that's not enough it's
about feeling it on a regular basis when
you know what your core value is and you
want to figure out how can I feel this
as much as possible every day of my life
because that is where the magic is going
to happen how do we create a morning
routine how to create systems how to
create a schedule that supports me
bringing as much of myself a much as
believe into the world as possible and
so for me I have a morning routine I'll
wake up and I'll put on my bullied
playlist and my belief playlist is a
YouTube playlist it's public you guys
can check it out and it just has songs
that make me want to move and you may
not like the songs and that's okay like
these are songs that I like you go find
songs that you like because when you
wake up music can instantly change your
state from being sleepy and tired like I
don't wanna get out of bed to boom this
is awesome and you're moving and you're
ready to take some action because when
you're when you start to move your body
it sends signals since this is exciting
it gives you more energy for the day in
my office I have five pictures on the
wall five five giant posters on the wall
right and those are all people that mean
something to me you may look at them and
you may not like the people have them
alone you mean lucky that I have no idea
of those people on the wall it doesn't
matter this is what makes me feel
believe on a daily basis the videos that
I pick for this channel make me feel
believe on a daily basis there's a
reason why I'm not putting videos up of
somebody hating on somebody else or
conflict of this person yelling at this
person and just fighting over on top of
each other if I did that I'd probably
get more abuse like we would rather as a
culture watch people tear each other
down then build each other up it's more
entertainment right it's easy to watch
that kind of stuff and it's just an
escape for your life and you're just
running away from a life you don't like
instead of purposely trying to build a
better life for yourself but I don't
have that kind of content on my channel
because it's not belief and so you have
the same thing inside you whether you're
making a youtube channel whether you're
certain to a dance company whether
you're doing some other kind of business
when you figure out what your most
important core value is and then you
design a life a business a schedule a
routine a mourning structure around it
you're gonna create a lot more magic
you're gonna unleash that inner genius
inside of you other world is gonna see
it the world's gonna pay attention
you're gonna have a big impact
so the question day today is I'm curious
what are some of the things that you do
on a daily basis to help you feel your
one word or help you feel excited
motivated pumped ready to go out and
start today one of the things that
really really really helped you share
down the comments below really curious
to find that maybe I'll learn something
too I'm excited to see what you guys
have to say I also want to give a quick
charter to Cara Weldon from CW
hospitality Co UK Karl thank you so much
for your support and picking up a copy
of my book your one word I really
appreciate it and I hope you enjoyed the
read thank you guys again for watching I
hope you have an amazing day I believe
in you I hope we continue to believe in
yourself and whatever your one where it
is much love and I'll see you again
tomorrow morning for another shot of an
espresso
let's pray so give me go
we'll talk about talent they say look
you are multi-talented and that's why
you're a superstar you differentiate
though between talent and hard work
absolutely new right I've never really
viewed myself as particularly talented I
view myself as you know slightly above
average and talent where I excel is
ridiculous sickening work ethic you know
while the other guys sleeping I'm
working while the other guys eating I'm
working while the other guys making love
well I mean I'm making love to but I'm
working really hard those Denzel
Washington right now is hooking up you
gotta go it's like the the separation of
talent and skill is one of the the the
greatest misunderstood concepts for
people who are trying to excel who have
dreams that want to do things talent you
have naturally skill is only developed
by hours and hours and hours of beating
on your craft and you know for me it's I
feel like I have a relationship with the
audience they agree that they're gonna
go in droves and I agree that every time
they go is going to be better than the
last time so I think that's part of the
the relationship and I'm gonna hold up
my part as long as they keep hold up
theirs and just really worked on my gift
I realized that all of us are born with
a gift but you gotta hone it you know
it's just not you're not gonna become
great and we talked about the school of
greatness you know we talked about you
know greatness is upon you and I
realized that my gift wasn't going to
create itself my gift wasn't going to
nurture itself my gift wasn't going to
perfect itself that was something I had
to do and so man before you know it we
did a video that went viral I think it's
got over 50 million hits now and we turn
our passion into a problem
we each have a gift but too many people
miss out because they refuse to sign the
lease on their gift you keep looking for
it outside of you stop sit with yourself
what is it that you do the absolute best
with the least amount of effort that's
your gift but if you are constantly
looking outside of yourself and you
don't latch on to your gift you will
never find your purpose if you want to
succeed you must commit to your own gift
and embrace it if you had to think of
one word that's most important to you or
that sums you up or
that would be collect a little beacon
pay believe nation if you want to know
what the most important one word is for
Tony Robbins Gary Vaynerchuk Oprah
Winfrey will.i.am and Howard Schultz I
have a very special secret video for you
check the description for details